being gay is natural or not ?
By [ed] so Highly [Simple] [Things] [Apart]
[Then] [I] don't know well
Assalamu alaikum Brothers and Sisters inshallah all of you are in the best of health and imaan and you are all doing fine you're Tuning in to
Another Episode of Ask the sheikh, We are here With our sheikh sheikh Haitham al Haddad
Inshallah Today's
Discussion Is going to be about sheikh,  Basically
There's A
Girl Or a Boy it Can happen in Both Cases They're Growing up trying to be a good Muslim
But They Start Discovering These New Tendencies Yeah
They Are Feeling Attracted to the same gender me a girl Starts Feeling Attracted to Girls the Boy Starts Feeling
Attracted to Boys yeah he's Feels that he's Turning bisexual or Gay
Can That Person still be a Muslim Is that Person Instantly a kaffir what happened yeah okay
Yeah This is yeah jazakallah khair alhamduliah assalatu wassalamu ala rasooliah  this is A very Interesting Question and
I think it Takes Time to add elicited from all angles yes
However I will Just maybe give A taste for our Brothers and Sisters Yeah
About This Issue Now See
I've Been Dealing with this case a lot
Okay for in Fact in the last A few Months I have the three cases Yeah a young boy
He Feels that he's a gay a young Sister She Feels that She's
Lesbian She Attracted
One of the recent Cases yes a young Boy he Came actually with his Father and he Feels that he Is a gay
I asked him a number of questions
Said to him
One key Question I want the Brothers and Sisters To ask Themselves This Question ya?
See in The Beginning When
The Young
Boy he is mixed With Young Boys he might be emotional Same [Thing] With sisters Which is as even it is bigger some are very
Emotional emotional in Generally Speaking at the
After Puberty
They Are emotional Emotional they want they want to be loved and They want to love someone okay yeah and
When
For example Boys or girls mixing With each other They might find that they are closed
Once Is that might find that she is Close To a particular Sister
Oh yeah and the Boy Feels that he Is close To a particular board
Yet Even Practicing People you know
They Might Feel [that] They are Close to each other They start what to do health of the whole run together
There it believe how, much Just the way They
Feel okay that They do helps Together then the Shaitan comes to them and Tell them that
Oh listen before you go to bed send Salam to the other Person after you go to bed send Salaam on to the other Person
Yes it Check Whether he has Said his adkar She has Said That adkar Etcetera so they
Develop The Relationship Like This, okay
Slowly Slowly as they as i said the Shaitan is Involving is Involved and then they Shaitan says
Oh use what Certain, words like, oh?
So so I missed you
Okay, I need to see you, okay?
okay
Yeah and then They start using Innocently This Kind of language More in The wrong Way not in that one Year that
Way so they become even More attached to each other okay?
Slowly Slowly, oh
The Each Side might Feel [that] he Can't Stay for Long Time away from
Seeing The other Side, okay yeah
Okay and then, oh?
I could not sleep because I could not see you for the last 23 Days
you Know
Yeah then the relationship develops is slowly Slowly until when they Come next to each other yeah they? Would like to sit?
Okay, next to each other They, Would like to hold hand they Would like to have some Physical Contact
okay, yeah
Then it Slowly Slowly shaitan(devil) our might Come to them with some Bad Ideas
Such as Let me be Open With Brothers and Sisters Yeah yeah this is young Boys and Young girls told me this yeah?
They Like to Spend Time
Together in Seclusion, no One With them they Feel happy together
Yeah Together alone then they might like When They stay Together they might like Hold Hands
for A long Time yeah, sometimes They like that the skin, will be next to the skin and
What May happen as it happened With some Boy some Girl
They Were
Sleeping next to each other not in A Bad Way but they Feel kind of love happiness
Yeah and then after some Time They shaitan(devil) and Comes to them and Tell them Take off
Your Clothes the skin to next to the skin, so it's a buildup, okay so it Is A
Build up Now I
Say to them okay because Now I have Experienced so that's why?
I didn't describe Target not happen ok
so yeah so i Can Explain This and This Is very important for
Those Brothers or sisters who Feel that they have this to Feel that the Person in front of them
Understand it so You've Seen, some Cases Where it's been Like when, you're Young I am all most of the Cases are Likely
[okay], so you are not Actually sexual Attraction yeah yeah
They do The very soul it might turn to be A sexual Attraction it might okay it Can Happen
okay
Now I ask Those Boys and Girls [i] said to them are you
Attracted To for example the Boy are you attracted [to] Boys
From the Tape Boys Yeah the Sister [I] asked her are you attracted to all the girls
Just all Just That Particular one
and I
Think in
In all Cases I don't remember a single case With the person  Said I am Attracted to all boys
Yeah Or!
Most of the boys Or maybe Let me be open so to the Handsome Boys
Yeah or the Sister I'm Attracted to
So on so girls know it is that
Particular, Oh Call for example Boys With This Feature Local or the air of you, ok, I'm going to that Particular
Ok, yeah!
and then Because of what We Read in The Media About Homosexuality and it is a natural thing and
Labeling
Yeah the issue of Labeling that
Ok, the Person who is Attracted to the same gender [yeah] it. Is put like this and
so he it is a natural for him to be Attracted to the same gender it Is
Natural For her to be Attracted to the same gender this is Called
Homosexuality ok, yeah so they start Labeling Themselves Like This and They start to Internalize
This and then The problem Becomes Bigger, We'll stop here We will?
Continue in The Coming Episode This, Is that as I said Is just a taster, ok?
Inshallah inch okay so guys I want to thank you for Watching
Basically This is Part 1
Addressing This Topic Inshallah Stay Tuned for Part 2 and
Yeah, we're Going to get Into that Inshallah if You Have Any more Questions for Sure hate them email Us at the email Below Take
Care of Yourselves Salam Aleikum
He Feels that he's a gay Young sitter she Feels that She's Lesbian
Again as well
you Know in Order to deal with This
The [Young] Boy okay that are dealt With him Recently and in fact I dealt with so many Young
Hey Give Me one I'm sorry subscribe